[Musik]
der doppelte punkte
auf diesem markt bekommen die kundinnen
und kunden immer etwas mehr als nur
gemüse ein offenes ohr zum beispiel
vertrautheit oder schlicht die welt ohne
gewissheit das osi freitag und wert
waldvogel zweimal die woche da sind bei
wind und wetter seit jahrzehnten
[Musik]
die gärtnerei freitag liegt in opfikon
direkt an der stadtgrenze zu zürich der
markt mit den vielen kundinnen und
kunden ist das herzstück ihrer arbeit
was kriegen wäre da ist also eher ich
danke woche entlang lübz sie erraten
oder also been tochter dass ich mich
erkennt glaub so viel
ich glaube also einfach in einer klinik
schaffte natürlich
diese erde bedeutet osi freitag mehr als
das halbe leben seit sie sich erinnern
kann sind ihre hände mit diesem boden
verbunden
die großmutter und der vater fuhren mit
ross und wagen auf dem markt damals noch
an die zürcher bahnhofstrasse
seit drei generationen
verdient die familie freitag ihren
lebensunterhalt mit gemüse
das ist für mich
eigentlich
gut schmecken sie wahrscheinlich die
erklärte finden
ich sagen was haben sie und lust und
gebraucht wird vor allem natürlich
schließlich nach gerät jetzt sei im
moment die boni verhindern
vor 30 jahren hat bert waldvogel orsi
freitag kennengelernt von beginn weg hat
er sie in der gärtnerei unterstützt übte
aber während jahren weiterhin seinen
beruf als per kran führer aus
1995 schließlich stieg fiat waldvogel
voll in die gärtnerei ein
das geht aus am
das land das die gärtnerei freitag
gestellt gehört ihr nicht es gehört der
stadt zürich um die mitte des letzten
jahrhunderts kaufte zürich in opfikon
landreserven um die stadtentwicklung
besser steuern zu können
[Musik]
seit anfang der 50er jahre sind die
freitags hier pächter
vor zehn jahren hat die stadt zürich den
pachtvertrag gekündigt auf zusehen hin
durften die gerne aber noch bleiben
statt züge dies sei nicht außer ganz
sicher 2012 geblieben wie sich
deutschland als 13 schieber zum verkauf
oder im baurecht also wirklich können
wir ganz sicher nicht
genau
es ist november 2011 die gärtnerei
freitag ist einsam geworden die anderen
bauern und gärtner haben das einstige
kulturland schon verlassen das oberhaus
rangiert in opfikon heißt jetzt
glattpark
die lage am stadtrand von zürich und die
nähe zum flughafen kloten ließen den
wert dieses landes seit den 1960 er
jahren kontinuierlich steigen zu zeiten
der hochkonjunktur waren die pläne
gigantisch in den 80er jahren trug das
oberhaus rangiert den titel teuerste
wiese europas den fantasien am reißbrett
schienen keine grenzen gesetzt
zur berlin serie 7 hektar großes
landstück hier unmittelbaren der zürcher
stadtgrenze werden banken
verwaltungszentren und gewerbe häuser
gleich im multipack in die höhe gezogen
sind 20 30 arbeitsplätze dem oberen
reaktoren zehn minuten zum flughafen 15
minuten bis zur city von zürich sind
investitionsniveau mindestens zwei
milliarden franken
werde die beste freie zone goldene
zeiten für die boten besitzer die preise
steigen bis zu 4000 franken pro
quadratmeter
über 20 grundeigentümer teilten sich die
rund 70 hektaren grosse wiese es dauerte
mehr als 40 jahre bis sich landbesitzer
politiker und bevölkerung darauf einigen
konnten was mit diesem land geschehen
soll im jahr 2000 stimmte die optiker
bevölkerung und der kanton zürich dem
neuen quartier plan zu
seitdem steht fest hier entsteht ein
komplett neuer stadtteil mit wohnraum
und arbeitsplätzen für insgesamt etwa
14.000 menschen
[Musik]
seit herbst 2006 sind die ersten häuser
im glattpark bezugsbereit
bei diesem mann laufen alle fäden
zusammen
er kennt jeden investor jeden bauherrn
alle involvierten behörden und sämtliche
pläne im auftrag der grundeigentümer
kümmert sich bernhard stähler schlicht
um alles offiziell heißt das gebiet
marketing
und da sind wir jetzt
natürlich gerade wie der fluglärm das
gehört so ist aber jetzt kein fluglärm
ist kein flug zu können ist es sehr
ruhig um es im plötzlichen der
wohnsituation es
speziell wahrscheinlich das faschierte
mieter oder eigentümer gesät bis ansehe
arbeit also ganz ohne ist noch eine der
serie also vor jedem balkon statement
ließ fiddy
das ist alles verwertet was sie da und
ich bin aber aber bis zum ganz froh dass
er da ist wohl mit neuen schwer alle mir
das andere ich schon immer dass sie das
zeigen mich freut wenn sie nicht aus der
baum
der stattliche baum könne erhalte werde
und
natürlich nimmt der küste mir trotzdem
den weg es geht nie toni 27 aber er ist
letzten relikte eigentlich aus dem
oberhaus rangiert wo man noch sieht man
sie auch vielfach dramatik da liegt rund
um sitze und baumärkte
inzwischen leben rund 2000 menschen im
glattpark vor knapp vier jahren nahm das
erste restaurant seinen betrieb auf
weitere sollen folgen
alle miet wohnungen sind vermietet alle
eigentumswohnungen verkauft
eine 100 quadratmeter große
eigentumswohnung war 2006
durchschnittlich für
460.000 franken zu haben seitdem haben
sich die preise stark erhöht
bei projektstart sei die stimmung
skeptisch gewesen er habe zwar immer an
den erfolg geglaubt sagt bernhard rom
stand aber noch vor zehn jahren hätten
viele leute gemeint hier wolle sich ja
niemand wohnen
da sind wir natürlich wieder eine ganz
verrückte momentum früheren auf der
wiese stand das sind und wo man auch sie
sind auch nicht besser
2002 so ungefähr 40 jahre
visualisierungen machen die allererste
mit dem see und park mit erster plan
und ganz am schluss habe ich noch ein
oder zwei drängte ihn ersetzen oder
irgendwie vielleicht hat das nach vorne
und wurde sehr sie pro jahr
ungefähr im
baugebiet eine schilf insel sind so zwei
andere 4x sie mitglied sind so zwei
jahren abflogen und irgendwie zwei
zähler miteinander findet das gut da und
dann setzt er aber und das ist für mich
ganz wichtig und manchmal kann es
funktioniert dass mirco nicht willig
damals anderen zeichnet an sondern will
wählt glüht achtet also wie sie sagen
wie ich akzeptiere das
dass hier ein künstlicher see mit einem
park steht war ein langer politischer
prozess inklusive volksabstimmung
sie werden zwar 15 baustelle mit 30 bis
50 grad wird es da bei den nächsten zwei
jahren wird das schiff drei riesige
baustelle war jetzt darauf alles durch
und alles ist eigentlich geplant der
lücken wo in der letzten zwei jahre was
eher ruhig sie sind wo wir sein penny
marshall loslaufen im glattpark an der
problem und dann nehmen wir sagen haben
sind dort planen planen und auch und
schaurig viel ändert da aber blüht waren
die baustelle sehen glaube zurückwies
seit 40 jahren schaut die familie von
osi freitag zu wie zahlreiche projekte
aus dem boden gestampft werden und
wieder verschwinden
aber dieses mal wirken abschied war
momento variante
wählen
es ist doch so lange muss man drehte sie
ist keineswegs
[Musik]
geordert worden
das geht natürlich - oder eben mein
geschenk sich solche müsste ich irgendwo
die hat ausgespielt man sich nicht
darüber geredet also
konkret also oder weiß ist wenn er sich
massiv
reduziert muss ich bin aber geordnet ich
aus meinem schnitt ordnen sind vorfahrer
ich spüre dass ich
gut meint die es machen wir nicht angst
es ist wohlwollend gegenüber mir
wirklich beschützen und sich das muss
inzwischen ist die gärtnerei von
baustellen beinahe umzingelt die gärtner
sind aber entschlossen weiterzumachen so
lange es geht
mit dem staub wie es mit deiner großer
mutig liegt bremen vorn jobs starb gab
es bislang
nicht aus 72 rasche salatproben im
schnitt einfach seriös
aber so ein zeug damit
auch nicht beim natürlich mit auch mit
einreichung und
aber mir eigentlich mit der
polizei wodka sind gewinnen und oder die
gesichter dieser band
und im ressort sächsisch
[Musik]
aber glücklich
mit meinem
sohn vertrauen
geben das sie dann hat auch der wahl wo
man hat immer recht
[Musik]
so das sind jetzt würden die allerletzte
tomate was
als chef der von extra
wahrscheinlich werden es die letzten
sein noch hat sie freitag keinen
definitiven bescheid wann genau sie die
gärtnerei räumen muss aber in gut einem
jahr schon ist direkt neben der
gärtnerei die grundsteinlegung für ein
großes geschäfts und wohnhaus geplant
der grossraum zürich gehört zu den am
stärksten wachsenden regionen der
schweiz im glattpark direkt an der a1
sind inzwischen alle großen investoren
mit von der partie großbanken
versicherungen pensionskassen dass sie
alle kommen war noch vor zehn jahren
nicht klar
das luxus autohaus schuler ag gehörte zu
den allerersten investoren aus
platzgründen so die schmohl ag vom
noblen zürcher seefeld an den glattpark
geschäftsführer matthias rascher hat
sich für diesen standort entschieden als
da noch gar nichts stand
es hätte auch eine sieht es danach gar
nie passiert ja das risiko an ja
eigentlich so nicht gesehen ich bisher
über zog sie vor der präsentation herum
schauen dass da etwas passiert dass ich
sehr viel dynamik sie bewegt in xi an
natürlicher bauch und verrät wo der
wagen immer so toll von der hand alles
was vom see über nabokovs seefahrt das
ist stoppt sieht für die nyt dass ich
jetzt weniger wort aber die ganze umfeld
um terium findet standort eigentlich gut
warum das problem entschärfen mit
holding service und flughafen erst
später große rolle
das sind viel unterwegs und sind dadurch
minute weg vom flughafen gekentert
dienstleistungen bringen sobotta
[Musik]
ich bin eigentlich ein naturverbundener
mensch
bis bald dann mehr bauen dann hat natur
leider kein platz mehr und da muss man
aber da wird die sich mit dass sie das
schöne grün und und höher und natur und
das da beides miteinander kommt ist eher
unwahrscheinlich man mit dem see hin hat
man sicher dem wissenschaftler aber es
ist klar
überzogen und david wenig platz dafür
gehören landschaft dem sie
[Musik]
es ist februar 2012 die ungewöhnlich
tiefen temperaturen lassen das wachstum
einen moment innehalten ein letztes mal
versinkt die gärtnerei in einem ruhigen
winterschlaf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es wird dann auch gleich mit einem lied
wo man spaziert ist ja dass man genau
ich ziehe die
begegnungen und gespräche keine
zufrieren arena das
ursprünglich
einfach mal ausland nabu existenten
natürlich immer viel league spaziert
wie reagieren die liegt was hier
eigentlich dass linda wird jetzt
schockiert
sie sich sehnt sich langsam natur
weg auch immer mehr
aber ich sage mir waren die anderen
mitbewohner
dann haben wir immer mehr liegt also
braucht immer mehr honig
in einigen monaten schon soll hier der
bus durchfahren
[Musik]
morgens um vier fahren wo sie freitag
und bergwald funkel auf den markt wie
immer zwei mal pro woche ja ein ja aus
auf dem flohmarkt am stadtrand von
zürich kaufen sie gemüse und früchte
dazu die sie selber nicht anbauen auf
diese weise können sie fast alle
kundenwünsche erfüllen
ja
das hat so ist das ganze ja es ist wahr
für den 67-jährigen wert und die
55-jährige osi war immer klar sie werden
keine andere gärtnerei übernehmen und
auch keine neue aufbauen
vorläufig sollten sie mit der pension
und der ahv von derart über die runden
kommen dann werden sie weiter schauen
[Musik]
die serie führte habe
im mai 2012 werden die ersten baugruben
neben der gärtnerei ausgehoben mit einem
investitionsvolumen um die drei
milliarden franken ist der glattpark die
größte baustelle der schweiz private
eigentümer
[Musik]
je nach nutzung kostet der quadratmeter
hier zwischen 1000 und 3000 franken
was macht es da dass wir die zwei
hastemir den abfall trittin und denn
dort ist das da heißt
die gurte plötzliche royce haben dafür
hier verbringe ich hier mache das was
sie gar nicht immer gut gehen denn aus
der kompost aber das ist er nicht
wir
brauchen eigentlich
nur 1,9 prozent
es ist mir eigentlich sehr wichtig wir
doch immer nach
elan vielleicht einmal verhungert dass
ich die 1 geschichte
braucht ihr euch hunger hand
[Musik]
um ihr verbraucht also darum aus zu
viele ressourcen
und das irgendwann für ihre generation
sehr knapp brent werde wahrscheinlicher
bereitgestellt
[Musik]
außerdem verkaufe für 15 franken
und ich auch eine profitieren das hotel
wertsteigerung das ist ja wie wann bitte
bitte bundes gras wächst
das machst einfach sie mit sehr gut ab
und
raus bist steh ich weiß sehr genau wie
viel sie über zwei haupt musik pro
quadratmeter das hat die beträge
wir sind heute alle zusammen oder
lang von der stadt amtlich bis zu der
ich bin kleine baumeister und ich an ihm
effizient als mit dem brand ich auch
eine schaffen von morgen bis am anblick
wie waren sie das stück lang hat und
dass ich mir wert wurde
bruno booties vater suchte in den 1950
er jahren eigentlich nur einen
lagerplatz für sein baugeschäft das land
im oberhaus rangiert war damals wenig
interessant und entsprechend billig er
kaufte drei landstücke vor zwei jahren
hat die erbengemeinschaft booty das
letzte der drei landstücke verkauft
und das ist verteilt wo das würde 10 12
personen
ich selber habe ihr neues buch
und ich muss sagen ich werde ich gut
fahre das mit investiert hat einmal
anteilnahme aktien investiert aber das
ist es nicht geschafft sich also nur um
ihnen das erklären
es gab
dann weg wie sie nach und und immobilien
[Musik]
der ehemalige bad robot die kennt im
oberhaus rangiert praktisch jeden
grashalm der rundgang im glattpark weckt
erinnerungen an seine kindheit
[Musik]
wir sind am stadtrand aufgewachsen
doch und das kapiert ist einfach nur
richtig natürlich sind mir einige
frösche fangen man keine grafische
machen können denn ältere unter den
augen fort ohne dass es gemerkt hat und
das ist also schon interessant was macht
das pärchen zusätzliches gewicht
platzmäßig ok kulturland messe der
fehlbetrag große garten
das land ist jetzt weg
ja also ich
finde es schön dass wieder an die
mannschaft dass wieder neue manchen gibt
wo da eine jetzt eigentumswohnung
gekauft womit als meter linie schaffte
mit abo als
leiter und darüber hinter mir gibt's
eigentlich wieder viele firmen
investieren wo also bald wie nachher
produkt zu kaufen das fasziniert mich
eigentlich
auch die bevölkerung ob kunz kommt aus
aller welt am food festival im glattpark
nehmen insgesamt 28 nationen teil
mit solchen anlässen versucht die stadt
opfikon ihre vielen neuen mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürger zu integrieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in den letzten zehn jahren verzeichnete
opfikon eine bevölkerungszunahme von 30
prozent heute leben in der kleinstadt
gut 16.000 menschen und die stadt wächst
weiter allein der glattpark wird
nochmals tausende von neuen
einwohnerinnen und einwohnern bringen
also etwa wenn der held sagte damit sind
sie weg sie
ist wie fasziniert sie vom konzept einen
rückstau dann ist das ok -magazin flug
taxi und so und wenn ich mal darf der
platz der märkte am morgen
sonntag was er so nah produktion wir
sehen dann aber schlug die stadt stand
das schild hier entsteht eine staaten
dick so begann ein teich vor dem projekt
was pädagogisch meer sind fast zu
gleichen sie co
sie sind dann wären ja nie drin aber wir
sind einfach alle zu machen das hat das
berliner haus das hat ich bin 20 jahre
mir tut sie nicht so viel glück
hat
ja es ist sehr schön das ist sehr schön
man hat natürlich fluglärm
ich höre gar nicht
also für kinder ist wirklich sehr
kinderfreundlich macht sich sehr schwer
gemacht
und er hat kein verkehr keine autos
machen ein gedanke dass da ja
ja auf die ein politisches natürlich
sehr schade dass
der betrieb und der land vielleicht so
beginnt handlung natürlich sei das
gebiet wo es eine passive fuß gesetzt
hat bis sich die wohnlichkeit und um so
viele arbeitsplätze wie das metall
familie höchste charakteren auch hat
dort der brauch mal viel viel viel mehr
landwirt ihr euch vorstellen dass
blieben ich hoffe schwer
davon aus dass ich damit rechtloser als
arbeiter ich hoffe sie
laut einer umfrage der stadt opfikon aus
dem jahr 2010 ist die mehrheit der
bewohnerinnen und bewohner im glattpark
mit ihrer wohnsituation zufrieden
[Musik]
im herbst 2012 erhalten wert waldvogel
und osi freitag definitiven bescheid bis
ende april 2013 müssen sie die gärtnerei
geräumt haben
[Musik]
letztendlich seien studios aufgenommen
und da in einer woche richtig los diese
locken prozent deutlich da umfrage
positiver morgen mehr bruchsal immer
mittel finden immer nach pflanze
mit den angaben
nach einer republik
und das wird auch sie krisen um die
wunderschöne logenplatz
[Musik]
seit ihrer kindheit lebte sie freitag
mit der unsicherheit ob sie hier bleiben
kann oder nicht zum ersten mal in ihrem
leben hat sie jetzt gewissheit
ich danke sowie
butter sich nach keimen
es wäre zeit auch
sondern nach oben
und alles kommt
[Musik]
dies halten
und so glaubt sie
[Musik]
man hat ja christmann dzeko aber
ungleich etwas so wie ich ist es wenn
ein stück speziell
für sie und bat ist es ein abschied auf
raten
bereits vor vier jahren wurde das haus
das sie neben der gärtnerei gemietet
hatten abgerissen seit da wohnen sie in
opfikon
wo sie hat keine kinder sie sagt sie
habe immer schon gewusst dass sie die
letzte gärtnerin der familie freitag sei
[Musik]
hat eine setze mich schluss mit
genveränderten nicht auf bäumen haben
aber die besteht
wird eine flanke doch viel fokus liegt
momentan
eigentlich nicht auf
so wie wenn ich rauche
anfang dezember 2012
das erste mal fährt der bus durch den
glattpark
alles nur noch vor den vorsprung
deutlich das selbstbewusstein konnten
ihre fahrt nach
kenia wo ich meine rede
[Musik]
direkt neben der gärtnerei freitag
findet am 6 dezember die
grundsteinlegung für den right place
statt eines der ganz großen projekte im
glattpark investorin ist die ubs
ricardo boss green ist chef des
schweizer immobilien geschäft der ubs
und herr über 13 milliarden franken
140 millionen
aber sind riesig 30 quadratmeter fläche
machen micro wellness mit radioshack
dreh unter quadratmetern im ersten stock
im bauch der varta micro macht
rechterhand unter dennoch den hammer in
den opferstock büroflächen und han 88
weniger sodass eigentlich denn je 140
millionen
wenn wir sie vergleicht was man alles
reiner bauer
sind vernünftig wenn wir aber erst hatte
das ist eine preissteigerung tore macht
dann hatten wir natürlich mehr
investiert
[Musik]
wie vertrackt natürlich hofft dass jeder
jede fläche zur betoniert wird will mehr
junge auf der andrea sie der verkäuferin
ihrer firma und branche und das sag ich
halt immer ein ohne ohne fortschritt hat
nicht kurz nicht wieder und darum finde
ich mir halt jetzt auch mehr in der
spitze lag das macht halt
generationen von der stadt vielleicht
mehr verdichtet bei
interviews nutzen kann und dafür den
außerhalb von den agglomerationen
grünflächen für unsere kinder und
grosskinder und zum erholen das mode
kreieren partei
[Musik]
mit oder ohne klub rechtsschritte und
ich mir schon vorstellen
es ist für mich
mal sind es spezielle lied anders denken
dass ich natürlich braucht ihr gar nicht
so natur
doch kann ich mich dann hat monika sind
sehr schön hier mal einige sehr
großzügig aber
es ist speziell
du kennst du bon dieu
aus riesa sind mit dem bob petersen
baden
die einfachen
ja kann ich schon
wie name ist gut zusammen zum beispiel
war ich so einen wunderschönen baum
pflanzen zwar gegenwehr klinik stutzt
aber wenigstens eins im stall um
das ist doch schon mal ganz schön ja
absolut 12 volt dazwischen
die welt von rosi freitag rückt mehr und
mehr in die vergangenheit
[Musik]
es gibt noch viel zu tun über die jahre
hat sich manches angesammelt in einem
monat muss der schopf geräumt sein
zwischen roxette atmosphäre hat sich
vereinen
das auch lieber die ja das ist ganz ganz
schwierig zu unterscheiden da immer so
extrem war die nok kraft
vom 1
analysiert und ist für mich dabei
schützt und
seetransport sie bilder
negativ
dort im land
ich war wichtig dass ich dir also mich
braucht das sterben zu sterben das
stimmt ja die
städtischen betriebe
dann ist dieses noch schlimmer
aber ich muss
die kraft nach
si
[Musik]
mit hohem fieber kämpft sich rosi
freitag durch den letzten markttag
[Musik]
ja
euro
[Musik]
heute zeigt kommen ja ja ja ja
[Applaus]
vor 45 jahren baute der vater von ursi
den garten shop eigenhändig auf
[Musik]
es ist april 2013 und zeit den schopf
abzubrechen in zwei wochen müssen sie
weg sein aber
muss
[Musik]
aber
[Applaus]
[Musik]
inzwischen haben sie und bat einen
kleinen garten für ihren eigengebrauch
gefunden dort sagt rosi freitag wird sie
versuchen ihr urvertrauen wiederzufinden